(light music)
- [Narrator] Huawei, the
world's largest maker
of telecom equipment
became a global leader
in designing cutting edge chips,
rivaling those made by
Samsung, Apple and Nvidia,
but ever since the US imposed
sanctions against Huawei
in 2019, the Chinese tech
giant has been losing
it's foothold in the
global smartphone market.
- The restrictions that
came down on Huawei
in 2019 certainly took
the company by surprise.
The US for a long time saw the company as
a national security threat,
but it took quite a few
years for Washington
to kind of really mobilize itself and take
some serious action against the company.
- [Narrator] A spike in
demand has contributed
to the global chip shortage,
but ongoing US China political frictions
have exacerbated the situation for Huawei.
So what led the us to impose restrictions
on the Chinese tech giant?
First, the US has long seen Huawei as
a national security threat,
especially as it was advancing
so quickly in 5G technology.
- This was seen as a problem
amongst some US policymakers
who have long been concerned that Huawei
telecommunications gear can
in some way be intercepted
or tapped by the Chinese government.
- [Narrator] Huawei has
denied this allegation.
Two more reasons for the
restrictions, allegations
of intellectual property
theft and violation
of trade sanctions.
In 2019, the US charged
Huawei with attempting
to steal trade secrets from T-Mobile
and with violating trade
sanctions against Iran.
- The alleged fraudulent
financial schemes used
by Huawei and its chief financial officer
were not just illegal, but
detrimental to the security
of the United States.
- [Narrator] Huawei previously denied
all of these allegations,
but in September the
company CFO reached a deal
with the US admitting
to some wrongdoing in
the Iran trade sanctions case.
Both cases are still ongoing.
Later in 2019 the US placed Huawei on
what's called the Entity List,
banning US companies
like Google and Qualcomm
from working with Huawei.
Then in 2020, the US tightened the terms
of the Entity Listing twice,
cutting Huawei off from
its own chip manufacturers
and then later blocking
Huawei from accessing any chip
built using US technology.
- Us technology is so deeply
embedded in the supply chain.
So, this was a truly destructive
measure that blocked the
company from chip makers, not
just in US, but in Taiwan,
in Europe, even in mainland China.
- Despite the restrictions,
any company that wants
to sell to Huawei can apply for a license
from the US government.
But these are often difficult to get.
- For example, Qualcomm is able to sell
4G chip technology to Huawei.
Other companies are selling
more rudimentary chips
to Huawei, and you can
see that that's really
an offshoot of this underlying
desire and policy circles
in Washington to reign
in Huawei's 5G technology
without totally sort of
choking off the company
from any components whatsoever.
- Since September 2020,
Huawei has been relying
on its stockpile of chips,
but its supply is now running low.
Huawei is investing in
domestic chip makers,
but it could still take
them years to catch up
to US technology.
Huawei released a new phone in July,
but without high-tech
chips it can't connect
to 5G networks and analysts say it will
struggle to compete globally.
In September, Huawei deputy
chairman, Eric Schuh said
the company's smartphone revenue will drop
by up to $40 billion this year.
And so far there haven't been
any signs from Washington
that the US will loosen
these restrictions.
- You're seeing Huawei pull back on 5G.
You're seeing Huawei
lose out on 5G contracts.
You're seeing it's 5G phone
sales totally collapse.
And in many ways this was the
goal of some of the sanctions.
(bouncy music)